in 2029 a mysterious global blackout led
to decades of chaos and anarchy the old
nations disappeared
countless micro states emerged
developing their own beliefs and
cultural identity
these are the tribes hey guys pete here
dark is my favorite netflix original of
all time so i got pretty excited when i
saw the trailer for tribes of europa
and noticed the mention that it was from
the producers of dark
that was enough to get me to watch the
first three episodes in an early
screening
and i thought i'd put together a video
about those a mostly spoiler free review
since so many of my subs came to my
channel through my dark videos
because like me you're probably
wondering is this the next dart
the answer to that question is probably
not where dark had this layered story
with multiple timelines that always kept
you trying to put the pieces together
tribes of europa is relatively
straightforward and it's storytelling
so unless what you've really been
missing is the german language and your
tv shows
and oliver masuchi the two shows don't
have that much in common
but that doesn't mean that there isn't
mystery in tribes and while it hasn't
sucked me in in the same way as dark did
i'm interested to see how the final
three episodes of the first season will
play out
what's going on here then tribes takes
place in 2074
in post-apocalyptic europe mystery
number one is what actually happened
back in 2029 that made things the way
they
are there's talk of a mysterious
catastrophe known as black december
because it caused a global blackout but
at least our main characters who were
too young to have first-hand knowledge
of the old world
don't seem to know what actually
happened on that day what followed was a
collapse of the world we know
and 45 years later there's conflict
between the tribes that emerged in the
aftermath we follow a trio of siblings
from the peaceful
originy tribe keanu live and
elia their tribe considers technology to
be the reason the old world crumbled
so they try to live a peaceful life
withdrawn in the forest
living in harmony with nature we meet
three other tribes
in the opening episode the crimson
republic which is
organized like a military outfit they
seem to be trying to put together
something like a civilization
they claim to want to help protect other
tribes but the cost of that
is you basically get absorbed into their
organization
kind of their opposite is the crows who
come off somewhat brutal
they have this urge to expand and even
enslave some of the other tribes but
then they also have this thing that's
almost like a samurai code of honor
where they don't lie
and if they give you their word then
they stand by whatever it is they told
you they would do
the most mysterious tribe is the
atlanteans the arrival of one of their
pilots
who crashes in the original territory
starts things off
somehow they still have advanced
technology and that includes a cube that
the pilot loses
as he crashes and elia gets a hold of
all of the other tribes know about it
and they want to find it first and
that's what brings them to the original
territory he was being followed by a
group of crows
that were being led by one of the more
interesting characters
lord varvara she's looking for the cube
from the wreck
her warriors swoop into the origeny
village
for a pretty violent affair and the
three siblings
get split up the youngest elia who found
the pilot
and the cube originally makes a promise
that he'll return the cube to the
atlanteans
because he was told it contains records
of enormous importance
and it carries a message which is
crucial for the future of humanity
the cuban it's creators of the second
big mystery when he's given the cube the
pilot pairs it with him so he has a
special connection with the artifact
he's told that it will lead him to the
atlanteans base
which is known as the ark while we don't
know much about the technology
otherwise all of the other different
tribes and various characters he
encounters want to get their hands on it
they all know it's valuable
as far as the atlanteans themselves the
character moses
tells elya that it's suspicious that
they still have technology at all
this makes him wonder if they weren't
behind black december themselves
since they must have been prepared for
it considering they didn't suffer the
same setbacks from the blackout that the
rest of the world did
the story breaks down like that keanu
and their father are taken prisoner
and are separated when they arrive at
the crow stronghold
of bratauk which is a sort of fortress
inside what used to be berlin
liv ends up with the crimson republic
after she's rescued by some of their
soldiers
elia is saved by moses who is looking to
get rich by
selling the cube because he's unaware of
what the boy has promised to do with it
we have a peaceful tribe torn apart by
violence in pursuit of some mysterious
technology
liv and keanu are determined to save
their siblings to bring the family back
together
and elia is on a mission that may be
vital to humanity's survival
overall the story is big on ideas which
means how satisfying it turns out to be
will depend a lot on what the answers to
those mysteries are
the vision for the post-apocalyptic
world they inhabit is fairly believable
you can imagine things turning out this
way the budget they were working with
probably wasn't enough to bring it all
to life but their location scouts
definitely did a good job in that
department the crimson republic's
headquarters especially
is an old museum that was built in the
mountains of croatia
the decay of the once futuristic
structure looks right at home in 2074.
most of the look works as i said
sometimes the budget seems a little thin
for some of the things they try to do
there's no glaring weak spots in the
cast
the crimson republic are a little less
interesting while the crows are pretty
cool but maybe a little bit too mad max
the motivations of all the central
characters were easy to follow
and while none of their performances
stand out at this point there weren't
any major problems there either
moses and barbara are the two most
memorable characters
moses and elia's journey is the most
captivating in what i've seen
moses doesn't appear to be affiliated
with any of the other tribes
and his quirkiness adds some humor in
life where elia is a kid
who is essentially a fish out of water
away from his village
since he's originally he doesn't really
know much about the outside world he's
curious about it
so he has this colorful character to
introduce him to things
since there are only six episodes total
in the first installment
i'd imagine we'll see things end on if
not a cliffhanger
than with an open question about what's
really going on with the atlanteans
this could work to its advantage keeping
the story somewhat tight
and then how that plays out could set
the stage for big things to come in the
future if they're able to pull it off
it's a fairly brutal but believable
world there's a pretty graphic
castration
and in general if you like the kind of
post-apocalyptic
dystopic aesthetic there's a good chance
this will be up your alley
and i'll leave it there not the next
dark but maybe something worth checking
out
i think it most resembles the netflix
show the rain
which also imagined that kind of
post-apocalyptic future
sorta had a good idea but didn't turn
out to be great in my opinion
hopefully tribes of europa will have
something more impressive inside their
cube
and by this time next year we'll all be
anticipating the next season
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
after i see the rest of the season i may
come back and do an ending explain video
so check back for that and thanks for
watching i'll talk to you soon